Maxwell here with another gamespot news
update where we have learned that the
playstation 4 version of watch dogs will
run at 1080p while the xbox one version
will not in a video interview that has
since been set to private but was seen
by CVG ubisoft cinematics animation lead
told pc games the first thing i want to
make clear is that at its core it's the
same experience on current-gen and
next-gen consoles you get the same
gameplay out of it he went on to say of
course there are nuances to it we are
utilizing Xbox one to its full
capabilities and the same with ps4 to my
knowledge on ps4 it will run in Full HD
this corresponds with reports from
earlier this year that claimed that the
ps4 version would run in 1080p while the
xbox one version went out put some
lesser resolution in other watchdogs
news ubisoft released a separate video
today demonstrating watchdogs utilizing
nvidia technology to create a vivid and
breathtaking chicago for the pc version
of the game watch dogs of course
releases on May 27 so there's still
plenty of time to bring the console
versions up to graphical par and for
more updates on watch dogs be sure to
head on over to gamespot com